Sharna Burgess and Bonner Bolton
continue to turn up the heat in the
Dancing with the Stars ballroom while
Heather Morris dances without injured
pro partner Maksim Chmerkovskiy and the
first couple of season 23 is sent home
[Music]
worst case scenario I am never coming
back on Monday night's episode of
Dancing with the Stars tensions ran high
as Max had to bow out of performing the
jive with Glee star Heather Morris due
to a major calf injury but Heather
nailed the dance with her substitute
partner Alan Burstyn they nabbed a 30
from the judges pretty dance for the
pretty lady Jharna Burgess and Bonner
Bolton hypnotised with their stunning
Viennese Waltz that had the judges and
the crowd swooning I feel like I'm like
and everybody else watching something
unfolding
[ __ ] wedding that was poetry emotion
tonight but despite several standout
numbers a one pair had to go home
the first couple to be eliminated this
season is Chris and Whitney
[Music]
14 years ago I broke my neck while I was
working here I want to see this x-ray
that's my back part of what I used to do
was physical comedy but now I can't it's
really sad when somebody says I missed
the old Chris that sucks here
it's crazy that somebody can have that
happen to them and then be brave enough
to try something like this
the couple opened up to et's Cameron
Mathison after the show when I got in
the show I was like you know the only
way I'm gonna do the show is if is if
they know that you know I've had surgery
and stuff I'm gonna look kind of like a
lame-o or whatever I'm not gonna look
healthy so because I'm putting myself in
a very vulnerable place can I ask what
your big takeaway from this experience
was it was an incredible experience and
working with Whitney was tremendous
[Music]